first up we're gonna bring up another
guy actually from tennessee they keep
coming here i don't know why
tennessee must be really bad
we're not worried about that get it from
matt boyd everybody
[Applause]
and his opponent one of the newest
regulars on kiltonline give it up for
hans kim
all right rock paper scissors let's get
this going hard
all right thank god that was faster
for hans and matt everybody
guys as adam said hans is a regular on
the kill tony podcast which means that
he gets to do one minute of stand up
every week and they also pay strippers
to come to the club and kiss him
i didn't know that make-a-wish was
sponsoring autistic adults
thank you trailer park gollum
you're welcome hacky chan
[Applause]
very rarely have i been a gold body for
someone
i look like a mad boy was on steroids
how does it feel to know that you'll
never be as masculine as an asian man
thank you mommy lee we appreciate it
hans has sex like he does comedy very
boring one minute at a time and whenever
tony hitchcliff tells him he can
[Applause]
[Music]
which is more than you ever have said
thank you disney channels boulogne
you want to find out yes
people going for the assistant coach for
our high school girls volleyball team
[Applause]
matt is as respected in the comedy
community as he is in the pickup
basketball
[Applause]
they community laughter is the best
medicine but you should still take your
testosterone
[Applause]
hans looks like he jerks off the
mythbusters
thank you resting snitch face
[Applause]
matt boyd is not a pedophile
because if you're a child and you can't
overpower a mat boy that's on you
[Applause]
[Applause]
hans hasn't told his parents yet that
he's a tony's lap dog
he's not embarrassed he's just afraid
they'll try to eat them
[Laughter]
he's the only reason you think you're
funny
he's the same size as you are
he's as funny as you are so
no one knows you
[Applause]
your whole youtube channel is about to
keep it going
um
give it up for the tiniest confederate
monument
[Applause]
the only way to take down this statue is
with a lawn mower
hans has a lot in common with the
homeless people here in austin
he lives in a van he annoys people on
sixth street and he lost a lot of people
in the korean war
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that point is what happens to you when
your mom smokes drinks snorts shoots up
and goes on roller coasters
[Applause]
[Applause]
for these guys
let's see who thinks matt boyd makes
[Applause]
that's pretty close i'm thinking maybe
one more joke
all right
matt boyd has a perfect body for begging
on sixth street
you just do my last joke
he's what men would look like if hillary
clinton got elected
[Applause]
hans looks like if ryan gosling stared
at the sun for too long
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
oh
good job boys
[Music]
[Applause]